in death he has nothing left to
[Music]
fear keep him away from ace chemicals
your Vengeance will come
Oracle whoever this guy is he's
assembled an army got something here
from a Black Ops operating in vuela
there's nothing but speculation on their
Commander though the only thing sources
agree on is his name the
Arkham there's a crew of ace chemicals
workers left on site they'll be able to
help us track down scarecrow and locate
his
bomb
gates open time to bring in a
car
keep your guns trained
[Music]
up you're safe now they've been running
the plant for hours they brought in
trucks weapons soldiers shipments of
hazardous materials they knew exactly
what they were doing where do I find
scarecrow
all I know is he's moving ahead with his
plan and he's got a whole freaking Army
backing him up we're screwed Batman I'll
stop him but first I'm getting you out
of
here great work I knew you wouldn't let
us down we're not done yet Jim I'm going
back for the
others
going
now
[Music]